hi everyone i'm david griffin and i'm
here to bring you a review of bioshock
infinite burial tea episode 2 final well
most likely the final dlc installment
for the bioshock infinite game which was
one of my top games the beer if you
remember if you checked out Michael and
I did our video game of the Year picks
not definitely though it did win my game
of the year BioShock Infinite was
definitely in my top five for game of
the year it's kind of a you know it's a
lot of a sad day to talk about bioshock
infinite because you know rational games
i was in the news a little while back
Kevin ken Levine the one of the heads of
the studio said there they laid off a
bunch of people they're going to go in a
more smaller game direction less
triple-a titles and you know I love the
bow shock franchise this isn't
necessarily the end of Bioshock we may
see more Bioshock games but I thought
BioShock Infinite and especially this
DLC what you want to talk about now
brought all of that story to an end for
those who've at least played bioshock 1
it's a story of you know this
underground world called rapture built
by this crazy man named Andrew Ryan a
very ambitious man of course BioShock
Infinite now brings in Booker do it and
Elizabeth and the first part we're not
going to spoil anything here there's
going to be a spoiler free review the
first part very we'll see part 1 you
play this Booker and Barrel see part 2
you pay play as Elizabeth and it is so
fun to play with her it's different it's
a different style with Booker it's more
guns blazing you know shoot first ask
questions later with Elizabeth you have
a few different styles of playing you
can go guns blazing well this game does
it gives you a sword it gives you more
of a stealth option not going to say it
goes full full on Splinter Cell or
anything or metal gear solid or anything
like that but you do do some stealth
elements a lot of sneaking around you
know begging guys upside their head from
behind you know killing some splicers
you know just how people do it's a great
game it's a beautiful game it's so nice
to be in rapture for those of you don't
know you know burial at sea is an
extension of bioshock infinite which in
the end i won't spoil it but just let
you know if you're debating like should
i get the dlc is even worth it it does
wrap at
thing up very nicely at the end in my
opinion since my opinion I actually
enjoyed this episode 2 as Elizabeth
Moore rated episode 1 as Booker I mean
it starts off in Paris just you know
just give you a hint of like the
beginning of it it's really cool scene
it's almost like a beauty the beast with
Belle you know singing bone jewelry of
all these people like talking to you and
she's all happy this is beautiful world
of course as everything in BioShock it
goes to crap because Bioshock all the
games the first one is rapture infinite
up in the clouds it always looks
beautiful on the outside and maybe when
the first time beginning it looks nice
was always a deeper darker something
else you know sinister going on you know
foul shot infinite it was issues of race
nationalism you know separation from the
United States with the same thing again
and with bioshock the first one with
rapture you know separation from the
world you know freedom but with that
freedom there's consequences nothing's
ever perfect you know human beings are
human beings as a bio suck Sheard series
has always talked about now I'm not
mentioning Bioshock 2 and this in the
reason why is because a rational didn't
really work on bioshock 2 it was made it
by different companies so I'm talking
about bioshock 1 now and bioshock
infinite because this I believe burial
at sea part two wraps all that up neatly
this is just been one of my favorite
games as I said before I think Elizabeth
is a great character Booker is also a
great character voiced by Troy Baker
Eiffel as you don't know it's Arkham
origins he was Joker for the last of us
which was Michaels game of the year for
him of the Year video you know he was
the voice of Joel I just doing some
amazing voiceover work and Elizabeth as
well great voiceover work there and
again probably one of my favorite games
this wraps everything up nicely if
you're in the bioshock infinite series
and just putting out this video to let
you know you should get the dlc I'm
can't really talk about too much detail
in the game as good as it is I don't
want to spoil because the pieces slowly
start coming together and everything in
the Bioshock world at least for
rationals view which is bioshock 1 and
bioshock infinite wraps up nicely i
can't recommend this enough pick up the
games if you've never played the whole
bioshock franchise I don't know when
we're going to see a bow shot game again
and if we are I don't know what to K is
going to do but irrational is going in
two different directions this is a great
entry final entry into the series
possibly final entering of the series a
bioshock infinite burial see part 2 you
know as always you've on chat with video
games with us you know you come check us
out at think hero calm we're also on
Twitter Michael and myself Dennis we all
play video games you know Michael had a
different perspective on bioshock maybe
check out his opinions be sure to watch
our video game of the year review to
hear his views on BioShock Infinite and
you know we're at think hero on Twitter
i'm at griffin de and of course you also
have a Facebook page you know please
give us a like spread the social media
you know just share everything our video
games TV reviews got game of thrones
coming up all that great stuff and
that's facebook.com slash think hero
fans